im labor ist der code des alltags schon
längst geknackt in tierversuchen werden
immer neue langlebigkeits rekorde
aufgestellt und nicht nur das auch eine
verjüngung der tiere gelingt
mittlerweile manche fachleute gehen fest
davon aus dass der alterungsprozess
umkehrbar ist und wollen das jetzt auch
in menschen versuchen demonstrieren wann
können wir also die ersten verjüngungs
tabletten in der apotheke kaufen und
wollen wir überhaupt ewig leben klicks
um science-fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpassen sie nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
manche lebewesen werden wirklich richtig
beispielsweise gibt es schwämme die 2000
jahre alt werden oder aber 4000 jahre
alte korallen im gewebe der westlichen
grannen kiefer lassen sich keine
anzeichen des alters entdecken und die
zellen der 20-jährigen bäume
unterscheiden sich nicht erkennbar von
denen der 4000 jahre alten bäume
doch bisher ist keine einzige kreatur
bekannt die biologisch gesehen
unsterblich ist doch ist die lebenszeit
dehnbar schaut man in die vergangenheit
könnte man das fälschlicherweise
annehmen zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes zeigen dass männer die
zwischen 1871 und 1881 geboren wurden im
durchschnitt 35 6 jahre alt geworden
sind frauen erreichen ein alter von 38,4
jahren für menschen die zwischen 2010
und 2012 geboren worden sind hat sich
die lebenserwartung verdoppelt frauen
werden 82 8 jahre und männer 77,7 jahre
alt doch aufgepasst das alles sind
durchschnittswerte und keinesfalls an
den dienst dafür dass die
lebenserwartung mit der zeit automatisch
ansteigt dass sich die lebenserwartung
hier bei uns quasi verdoppelt hat ist
zum einen mit dem rückgang der
kindersterblichkeit zu erklären und zum
anderen natürlich mit den fortschritten
in der medizin
dabei arbeiten forschungsteams weltweit
mit hochdruck daran die mechanismen des
alters zu identifizieren um sie dann zu
stoppen oder wenigstens zu verlangsamen
eine pille gegen das altern oder gleich
direkt gegen den tod wäre ja was und es
herrscht optimismus pur wie
beispielsweise bei dem us koreanischen
finanzexperten und 8 millionen juden
wir können den coaches alters knacken
und einen code den wir knacken
können können wir auch hecken doch es
gibt ein riesiges problem bei der
forschung zu menschlichen
alterungsprozessen nämlich dass wir so
lange leben und dass die probanden somit
die forschungsteams überleben bzw
mehrere generationen an
wissenschaftlerinnen notwendig sind
deswegen testen fachleute in diesem
bereich besonders vielen tierversuchen
so auch der fall bei einer aufsehen
erregenden studie eines kalifornischen
forschungsteams im jahr 2016 im labor
hatten die wissenschaftler innen mäuse
gezüchtet die vorzeitig altert die
spannende frage des versuchs lautete
kann dieser prozess im nachhinein
gebremst und gestoppt werden in den
zellen aktivierte das forschungsteam
dann die sogenannten yamanaka faktoren
die normalerweise nur in stammzellen
stadion aktiv sind die gene wurden über
eine längere zeit immer führen nur zwei
tage pro woche an geschaltet das
ergebnis war mehr als überraschend die
labormäuse lebten nicht nur um ein
drittel länger sondern erkranken zudem
auch nicht an krebs das forschungsteam
vermutet dass dies wohl aber passiert
wäre wenn die aktivität der faktoren
nicht unterbrochen worden wäre zudem
behandelten die wissenschaftler innen
auch gesunde aber ältere mäuse auf diese
art und weise die wunden dieser mäuse
verhalten schneller und nicht nur das
die tiere wirkten nach der behandlung
auch jünger der studienleiter juan
carlos im psycho belmonte sagt dazu
unsere studie zeigt dass alter nicht
zwangsläufig in eine richtung
voranschreiten muss der prozess ist
vielmehr formbar und kann umgekehrt
werden wenn man ihn sorgfältig reguliert
und es gibt weitere spannende
erkenntnisse aus dem labor nicht nur
durch genmanipulation sondern auch durch
hormone und medikamente ist es
fachleuten mittlerweile möglich den
alterungsprozess von tieren
hinauszuzögern fadenwürmer
beispielsweise leben durch die gabe
bestimmter wirkstoffe zehnmal länger als
normalerweise
doch bei aller euphorie ist auch klar
dass wir ergebnisse aus einem
tierversuch keinesfalls eins zu eins auf
uns menschen übertragen können die große
frage was genau uns alt macht ist ja
noch nicht einmal abschließend geklärt
dazu gibt es derzeit verschiedene
wissenschaftliche ansätze fest steht das
zelluläre veränderung den
alterungsprozess beeinflussen so
genannten telomere fungieren an den
enden der chromosomen wie schutzkappen
nutzen jedoch mit der zeit ab doch wenn
die telomere ihre funktion nicht mehr
richtig erfüllen erhöht sich das risiko
dass der körper erkrankt und zwar an den
typischen haupt krankheiten des alterns
wie beispielsweise diabetes krebs oder
herz kreislauferkrankungen andere
wissenschaftler innen sehen die
kommunikation der zellen untereinander
und die daraus resultierende
steuerungsfunktion von funktionen im
körper als die entscheidende grundlage
der verschiedenen alterungsprozesse
gestörte signalwege die im gesunden
körper eigentlich für
reparaturmechanismen zuständig sind
führen demnach zu krebs diabetes und
autoimmun erkrankung einigen
tierversuche legen diese theorie
tatsächlich nahe
hier konnte gezeigt werden dass
alterungsprozess verlangsamt werden
indem gestörte signalwege modifiziert
werden
wenn man ganz genau hinschaut scheuen
sich die fachleute mittlerweile auch
nicht mehr menschen versuchen zu machen
offiziell ist das so nicht denn die
behörden haben den kampf gegen das
altern bislang nicht als therapieziele
neuer verfahren anerkannt dennoch gibt
es klinische versuche doch diese laufen
in die richtung altersbedingter leiden
zum beispielsweise derzeit den usa wo
rund 3000 gesunden probanden 1 diabetes
mittel verabreicht wird konkret handelt
es sich um den wirkstoff metformin der
möglicherweise aber auch gegen die
leiden des alterns ankommen kann nämlich
gegen demenz krebs schlaganfall und
herzinfarkt die verlängerung des lebens
wäre dann also eine art nebenwirkung
eine spannende frage in diesem
zusammenhang ist ob sich die
menschlichen lebensspanne überhaupt ins
unermessliche steigern lässt nein sagt
ein forschungsteam aus new york die
wissenschaftler innen gehen davon aus
dass unser genetischer code es überhaupt
nicht vorsieht eltern zu werden demnach
beträgt die maximale lebenserwartung 115
jahre und das selbst unter sehr
günstigen umständen die fachleute
analysieren dazu globale demografische
daten und schrieben abschließend in der
fachzeitschrift nature dass der
genetische code von anfang an eckdaten
wie entwicklung und wachstum enthält
doch außer dem eben auch die mängel die
dann am ende zu unserem tod führen kann
gleich mal quasi mit dem fundament aber
dass ein haus gebaut wird es lässt sich
ja schließlich auch kein hochhaus auf
ein fundament setzen das ursprünglich
für ein einfaches bauernhaus gedacht war
in diese richtung weisen auch aktuelle
experimente vom max planck institut in
köln hin
die studien offenbarten dass sie vor
allem die afrikanischen knie fische als
passende versuchsobjekte eignen denn
einige spezies dieser süßwasserfische
leben nur sehr kurz schon mit einem
alter von wenigen wochen sind sie
geschlechtsreif kurz danach geht es mit
ihm bergab andere spezies dieser art
leben länger und zwar bis zu fünf jahre
mittlerweile nutzen forschungsteams
weltweit diese schillernde fische als
modell tiere um in der altersforschung
voranzukommen mittlerweile gibt es super
spannende erkenntnisse dazu die kölner
fachleute haben unter anderem
herausgefunden dass im erbgut der
kurzlebigen spezies komplettes chaos
herrscht möglicherweise lässt sich diese
erkenntnisse auch auf andere lebewesen
übertragen
das hieße dann im klartext dass eine
kurze lebensspanne auf genetische
verwahrlosung zurückzuführen ist defekte
und fehler in der dna sorgen demnach
also für das vorzeitige altern heißt
dann aber auch im umkehrschluss
diejenigen die lange leben besitzen
somit also gar nicht unbedingt bestimmte
schutzfaktoren bei ihnen haben sich nur
einfach keine fehler ins erbgut
eingeschlichen
genau dafür sprechen auch andere studien
unter anderem auch vom kölner max planck
institut trotz sehr detailreiche
analysen des erbguts von hundertjährigen
personen gab es quasi kein ergebnis
konkret konnten die fachleute also bis
auf drei genen nichts identifizieren
womit man das hohe alter der menschen
erklären könnte hier passt der vergleich
des menschlichen körpers mit einer
maschine
doch nach ansicht mancher fachleute ist
diese metapher suboptimal
denn auch wenn im sekundentakt zellen
absterben werden sie durch frische
ersetzt der körper repariert sich also
quasi ständig neu und diesen prozess der
instandhaltung sind der ansicht mancher
fachleute zufolge keine zeitlichen
grenzen gesetzt warum sollte das nur 50
jahren funktionieren und nicht 500 jahre
auf der anderen seite hat den natur kein
interesse daran geschöpfe
hervorzubringen die unsterblich sind
evolutionstechnisch sind alleine die
merkmale wichtig die den
fortpflanzungserfolg ausmachen dazu
gehört die unsterblichkeit keineswegs
sobald ein organismus für den
fortbestand seiner gene gesorgt hat hat
er seine aufgabe erfüllt das leben ist
dann nicht mehr wichtig zumindest aus
sicht der evolution und die wartungs und
reparaturarbeiten kommen zum erliegen
mal ganz abgesehen von den ganzen
biologischen faktoren selbst
die wissenschaft demnächst mal in der
lage sein sollte uns für eine längere
zeit jung zu halten gilt das nicht
gleichzeitig auch unbedingt für unsere
geistige jugend denn wie will man es
verhindern dass unser geist erfahrungen
sammelt die welt kennen lernt sich
weiterentwickelt und in diesem sinne
eben auch altert philosophinnen
diskutieren darüber ob irgendwann sogar
der zeitpunkt gekommen ist an dem der
menschliche geist soweit gealtert ist
dass der dazugehörige mensch gar nicht
mehr unbedingt weiterleben möchte fest
steht jedenfalls der ganzen
themenkomplex macht nicht nur moralische
philosophische sondern auch dringende
ethische diskussion notwendig denn nur
weil es demnächst wissenschaftlich und
medizinisch vielleicht möglich sein
könnte 150 jahre alt oder älter zu
werden sollten wir menschen das
eigentlich wollen
teure therapien die das leben verlängern
könnten sich vielleicht nur sehr reiche
leute leisten zudem gebe es wohl fatale
konsequenzen bezüglich der
überbevölkerung und der sozialen
ungerechtigkeit denn schon jetzt sind
die ressourcen der erde für so viele
menschen knapp und auch jetzt schon gibt
es maßnahmen die bevölkerungswachstum
verhindern sollen länger leben ohne sex
cooles video von spectrum video mit
redakteur lars fischer bekannt aus
seiner videoserie wir werden alle
sterben also anklicken anschauen fleißig
kommentieren und spektrum video
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran